but first to assess what we just saw
Charlie hurt of the Washington Times
joins us now shall I think so much for
coming up so if you think and and you
you know you really got to feel uh for
Ryan sick dick who's passed away
um and you've got to wonder about anyone
who would who who knew they knew that he
was not murdered by the mob but they've
claimed it anyway for two years and it
takes a very low kind of person to do
that to lie about a man's death like
that for political advantage and this
tapes this tape proves that's exactly
what they did now these people are truly
sick uh they're they're uh you know you
think you you know you think you know
how sick they are and then you see
something like this and you realize that
they're uh there is truly nothing no
body uh no event nothing that they won't
exploit and as Joe Biden said oh no this
is also about white supremacy and and
you know nobody uh you know nobody uh
comported themselves worse than the
Press did on this day and of course
that's three years afterwards
um and and the best example of it is to
look at the degree to which so many
people in the Press are so upset that
you got the tapes to and that you're
going to release the tapes I've never
heard of this I've I've never in all of
my life I've never known a press that
didn't want information to be released
that's what we have been fighting for
since the invent invention of the the
printing press and so and now we have
all these people they're so committed to
sort of the big lie that that the
government tells that they'll do
anything including uh you know
denigrating the name of a good police
officer and trying to hide the truth uh
in order to sort of prop up this this
propaganda and I and you know the deadly
Insurrection is one of them the other
one that they that they love to talk
about is the armed insurrectionists and
I remember at the time asking reporters
at the time you know why do you keep
calling these people armed
insurrectionists when there's no
evidence that anybody used any arms
against it and they said well they had
flagpoles so it's because people were
walking around with American flags that
made them armed insurrectionists
I I should say for viewers I don't know
you've been in journalism all your life
your father was a journalist you grew up
in this business and I agree with you
it's shocking to see how thoroughly it's
been perverted into what it is now to
support the government right active
defense of the people in charge it's
shocking Charlie appreciate it thank you
great to see you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight